what is happening there citizens of the reject
Nation we are going to watch Wednesday episode
4. today John how are you I am groovy and
ready to get spooky how are you I I like that
you know what else I like I like when you
guys hit the like button please hit that like
button it does wonders around here so please
go ahead and do that also subscribe and click
that notification Bell to get notified when
our reaction is up for the next episode of
Wednesday and uh full length Direction watch
along as we sync with your own copy of Wednesday
available for super sexy rejects on our patreon
page over there we cover several shows exclusively
with reaction highlights and watch alongs
included thank you so much to everyone who
has followed us on our patreon your support
means the globe we're overtaking it all right
guys let's do
it
foreign
gag
Dr kinbot tells me I should get out more it's
so cool yeah
what remains of the chest and torso indicates
a frenzied attack subject has been almost
entirely disemboweled yikes subjects left
foot is missing it appears to have been chewed
off at the ankle Beast has a necklace made
of feet appreciate you coming back to the
office Doug no problem Sheriff I thought you
should see this before I issued my report
on the latest victim it's a real noodle scratcher
the Killer cut off two toes from the victim's
left foot gross it's like a reverse nesting
doll at least I'm going out in style Friday
is my last day happy retirement duck I couldn't
surprise Mrs Anwar with a four-week cruise
hmm excited to trade rip shields for my ties
let him go talk he's your only friend I get
it
[Music] full rigor you've been dead a while
I guess you won't mind waiting another day
for me to cut you open oh [__] [Laughter]
but also oh [__] I think again luckily
great hiding spot five more minutes I was
just getting comfortable [Laughter] dude I
bet you have all kinds of sensory deprivation
experiences in one of those [Music] whoa what
a nut whoa turns out all of the monsters victims
have had body parts surgically removed the
first one a kidney the second one a finger
Wednesday I don't really feel like the third
one gallbladder murders aren't mindless he's
collecting trophies like a seasoned serial
killer it's quite impressive actually reaction
s got your smelling salts again
be happy you got color on your side of the
room now tweak to my back fencer the Orchid
produces a pheromone that mimics a female
insect once the plant is pollinated what do
the male insects get in exchange not a just
like all the guys at the Raven oh Burns achieving
a DJ haven't seen blood suckers how about
needles in my eyes could probably do that
anyway or you could invite someone and have
a little fun yeah follow the clues to the
dance
this is home see if you didn't get those scratches
from fencing he's hiding something he's hiding
a mislead yeah he's hiding Tyler [Music]
well I'm staying steady on my theory yep still
Tyler it's changes nothing
you just became that much more interesting
yeah but if he was bringing the life out of
the drawings they wouldn't be that sturdy
right I am not wavering Wednesday
Xavier what are you doing nothing
why don't you give me a tour maybe another
time why were you looking for me advice is
a dance and to say yes it's just about a certain
dance that makes you want to poke needles
into your eyes perhaps I'm all ears this was
my chance to get up close and personal with
a potential series how could I refuse are
you really going to make me ask
would you
would you go to the dance with me and then
projectile vomits I thought you'd never ask
neither did I
oh my god let's say Adams is going to the
Raven you need something that screams first
days stand back [__] I have arrived and
I know just the place oh where are we going
yeah our first roomy shopping spree the dance
committee's suggesting all white to match
the theme but that's not gonna fly with us
I just love the spirit of the show yeah I'm
going to seek helping I'm not stop
damn damn yeah get that one that is the one
are you going to the Raven this weekend I'm
not required to answer your questions out
in the wild am I
could bump into my therapist and say that
[Laughter] I don't require answer questions
out in the wild Emma I've followed you around
all week just to be able to say that person
who drew this at your suspect you bring me
some concrete evidence maybe we'll talk get
some concrete concrete evidence are you looking
for I'm gonna cast one of those freaking big
creature here so why are you sitting here
Lucas Walker I got a friend who works at hot
Couture she overheard you on the hunt for
a date to The Raven maybe we can help each
other out what's your game mayor boy you guys
the Raven coming up this weekend right I must
be the only one
we're going
it's an act of self-preservation sure that
happens I guess so who is it savior oh no
oh hope you two have fun I'm not sure why
you're becoming upset call me crazy Wednesday
but you keep giving me these signals it's
not my fault I can't interpret your emotional
Morse code that's a line that's a bar am I
in the more than friend zone or just a pawn
in some game you're playing I feel you man
Story of My Life bro I need to prioritize
thanks for clearing that up just give me a
call if I ever move up your to-do list ouch
how is he becoming more of the edgy badass
Wednesday you're a heartbreaker could you
get the shoe roomie putting a good word for
me I hear she still saw his date for The Raven
oh golly people like me and you were different
we're original thinkers Intrepid outliers
in this vast Cesspool of adolescents disrupters
you're not going to the Raven either actually
I am with Xavier I see oh poor Eugene Circle
I think I know where that is show me
oh yeah that's a very it's a very Tim burtony
hole versus
just a king chamber yeah it's just someone's
dungeon yachty Yahtzee what is that concrete
proof that's a bingo [Music]
God damn it
I came here to seduce you how do you know
what the Monster looks like were these all
just self-portraits oh what you think it's
me I saved your life so did the monster you
are so out of line right now I'm just trying
to uncover the truth and your art seems to
have a recurring Motif this creature's been
haunting my dreams for the past couple weeks
I try to block it out but I can't so I just
come in here and paint it when I was painting
this one the claws reached out of the canvas
and took a swipe at me wow damn you were in
here before when I caught you outside that's
the only reason you asked me to the Raven
isn't it I mean you'll still go right yeah
I mean we're still on you are unbelievable
it's nothing personal no it never is with
you is it I mean do you even care about anyone
or anything at all Wednesday yeah thing truly
the tortured artist definitely Tyler yeah
that's the claw of the monster and that's
a dried blood sample from a potential suspect
when the DNA test and see if they match I'm
not playing games Adams neither am I Sheriff
clearly she's done more for this investigation
than anyone on your team you know I figured
since neither you nor I have a date to the
dance we should go together right no oh so
we stuck out the cave and identify the monster
it's better than a dance you should have gotten
you cheating so I hear you might be free tomorrow
night after all you don't have a date already
I think she was waiting for him
[Music] just the tips what are you did you
get permission from Wednesday to do this
laughs [Music] a little Matchmaker thing
[Music] damn this is where vecna fought 11.
yep
someone dropped running up that hill right
now you were never more Student Life don't
you remember being full of Hope and excitement
about the Raven all our members disappointment
the boy I asked turn me down for another girl
Gomez go there that's he murdered her heart
I'm coming Eugene
Eugene oh no what have you done Tyler got
your invite guessing you a thing drop it in
the tip jar good guess your note was so genuine
and oh no Jesus Christ no now that I'm here
I'm glad I came no say yes how would you do
this to me
did he steal it somehow what did you pay for
it five finger discount yeah
[Music]
that's so great let's see this reveal shot
come on
I want to look that good in anything you look
unrecognizable ridiculous a classic example
of female objectification for the male gays
amazing I mean it wins that you look beautiful
give us a little smile girl you'd be a lot
prettier uh what happened to staking up the
cave oh [__] don't have this discussion
in front of Tyler he's the monster guess I'll
check out the woods myself don't go alone
it's too dangerous we go together tomorrow
night understood oh poor Eugene I'm afraid
Eugene's gonna die or get maimed or something
bad I don't know Palmer never strides away
from danger no no you know oh who are we oh
my God so sorry let me fix that [Music] in
it yeah yeah is that your date yes and he's
having the best time with me we are both loving
Let's Dance together don't cry Enid something's
not right does your mood have to do with a
certain pigtail goth girl
she's not here we are oh contraire I'm sorry
I do really like being here with you so I
appreciate the last minute invitation so then
we're talking about one you brought her up
yeah break your own rule [Applause]
[Music] time to dance dance girly yeah Heartbreaker
this is Tyler Galvin uh yeah double cab no
foam two pumps of sugar-free I'm gonna go
get us some drinks
uh you know each other but beyond the coffee
this looks like a fun ass event Netflix put
it on I come in peace that's a shame I brought
my pocket base
yep yep yep I love her so much I'm the only
one in the world who does I just don't see
what you see man you don't know what he did
to me
he killed my hour mom Xavier told me what
you did last year hey you and your friends
assaulted him and destroyed his mural on Outreach
day people do not [__] foot around issues
in this show why'd you do it I could give
you million excuses but the truth is I'm still
trying to figure that out um I did a terrible
thing but I swear I'm not a terrible person
I think Wednesday would be attractive that
kind of vibe do you think I was going to judge
you over some lousy prank I would have taken
it further yeah
there's a reason I liked you [Music] ah Sushi
you know the smiles coming is in her eyes
in the eyes yeah the smiles and just like
the subtle Communications with each eye emotions
so good so alive
oh [__] oh here we go
what is she doing
yes yes yes cool it's like some rubber already
issue yeah
look at that classic Wednesday dance
keep it going girl yes
[Laughter] so good
oh my God yes
I like how it's from like a 60s movie
she looks so hot right now this is so attractive
to you be drawing you all night
do me a favor what take off your amulet and
make me forget about it oh you broke up with
me because you thought I was manipulating
you with my siren song now you want me to
use it to help you get over another girl you
weren't supposed to bring her up so there's
gonna be like an extended sequence Netflix
will put that out as its own little special
like Roger's the musical or something guys
I was thinking that maybe this isn't such
a good idea I don't want my dad to get any
ball back or anything you know to get revenge
on those freaks for nuking crack Stones felt
yeah don't tell me you've got soft like Tyler
oh no don't get a don't get arrested
foreign
oh my God wasn't the sheriff was it my dear
Mother always says fire test gold suffering
test a woman that's a bar you don't know what
it's like never knowing people's true feelings
what about your amulet it's not foolproof
it's a mild prophylactic oh I I prefer them
getting along lucky do you tell
think of you everyone keeps saying that but
might not be entirely true honestly I wish
I cared a little more huh [Music]
I really don't want anything to happen to
this guy I'm Knight's gonna be okay
oh my God are they gonna kiss they might [Music]
uh Terry yep red dye in the sprinklers Blade
[Laughter] the only part of that movie I know
I just smiled what could be better [Music]
[Laughter]
the humanity
yeah you're gonna choke on that [Music]
YouTube Save YouTube Eugene is in the woods
he's in danger like I should wear it right
after yeah everyone's falling on the floor
just something's up with her you did this
I can't believe I fell for your crap oh ouch
I thought you liked me wolf ow wolf owl get
away from her Stone Kid Cudi Jr and his jerk
friends she blew me off you ever told me why
I was too embarrassed to tell you but I accidentally
looked in the mirror and kind of stoned myself
with my snakes [Music]
we should probably take it slow right totally
agree established a safe word yeah like I'm
dying my face
[Music]
Arthur two monsters over here
oh no
this is the shot [Music]
Eugene
oh no oh no
oh buddy oh my God is he alive [Music] oh
it just got personal ugh I know what's going
on okay all right get ready for it yeah I'm
ready for it the dad is the sheriff and he's
also okay I refuse to let go of Tyler I think
you might be I feel like there is some at
least at very very least yes that would make
the most that would make a lot of sense because
yeah he goes back to the cave he wipes the
evidence I feel like in the flash in the brief
flash I caught maybe a little bit of his beard
in there yes so yeah I think the big question
is yeah is he also monster or is he just trying
to cover up for Tyler but yeah she seems awfully
dismissive of concrete evidence surely does
yes and he doesn't seem to want much help
yes yeah I refuse to let Tyler go nope too
many signs no ah I just feel like whenever
I predict something and then I drop it that
you should have stuck to you eventually drop
it after some time and I'm like oh damn it
I shouldn't have dropped stick to it I I support
you I am still with you my guns I'm still
convinced um that was a great episode that
was the best one of the season so far yeah
man we dance dance with our hands hands hands
above our heads like Jesus said I thought
um all the genres and elements of this series
from you know the high school show to the
investigative mystery angle Supernatural qualities
I thought this was the and it was also like
wonderfully paced and it was really fun and
it ends in a way that feels like the investigation
is really personal now because you know they
had a moment with Eugene and Wednesday at
the very beginning when she was pretty much
identifying with him and they you know like
she she said in the last episode you remind
me of my brother and then in this episode
or like there's a certain kind of outcast
so they they do she does care for him right
and so now this is something where she really
does give a [__] and all these things
about not caring and everything I'm like well
that's completely out the window now like
she really does care and I thought this was
a just a wonderfully I thought I did a great
job of intercutting around all the different
plot lines going to Enid and Bianca and Xavier
like all of them I thought were really really
really interesting and I thought I had a good
ramp up until the very last shot it was really
well executed like I thought this breathed
really well and was the best edited one sure
and then even to have a moment where Wednesday's
dancing which um I wouldn't it's because that
dance is so it's a very because I I never
saw any of the dance but I did hear like there's
a there's a dance scene and um like I think
everyone did I feel like I might have seen
like an image of the dress at one point I'm
not sure it was around the time when I didn't
give a [__] about the shows I just probably
came in one with everyone yeah um so I didn't
bother to commit anything I saw it that's
good Glimpse that's good but uh yeah the the
even like the dance scene is is so specifically
fine-tuned to her character like you can't
just have her dance regularly or you can't
have it be something so obnoxious that it
feels like a cartoon like it has to feel within
really breakdown the ghoulish realm of of
Wednesday which I think having her dance moves
be something that feels a little bit like
the I thought of like the Thriller zombies
doing like a 60s dance yeah yeah the Thriller
mixed with just yeah that 60s era kind of
surf Rock just kind of like we're all kind
of wiggling and just following yeah it's not
a a specific like erudite dance steps kind
of thing yeah I thought it was I thought it
was excellent I I love this episode I thought
this from beginning to end like it started
off with a really great morgue scene and it
just kept ramping up and it it stayed and
I I thought everything coalesced in a way
that felt uh rewarding so I I thought this
was a really like this was their easily out
of the four this is the best one so far yeah
yeah I agreed it's it's I think the show is
done nicely to build steadily across each
of these four episodes we've seen thus far
and much in the same way this episode does
have just like a really nice gradual build
up to like a really nice chaotic Crescendo
and and yeah like I had heard it's funny coming
into the show I knew that it was like the
biggest show ever on Netflix or one of the
biggest you know viewerships but also you
know I'd heard some some differing reviews
about how it was executed and how good or
not it is and how much it leans into like
why a Trope or whatever else not really in
terms of specifics but just in just overview
and so here I've actually been so pleased
and enthralled by how much I'm kind of invested
in every element that they're going for like
I like just spending time with the kids and
thinking about the previous episode we watched
even having like I'm sure the the um Nightshade
Society or whatever that is will come back
but even that like I'm almost not mad that's
not more of a thing because this has sort
of managed to while not completely separating
itself from comparisons we were making earlier
to things like a Harry Potter or whatever
else like it does have its own unique Adams
family-esque charm and I don't feel like I'm
watching Riverdale or something even though
you have certain elements that are certainly
akin to that so like I think it's at least
for my viewership done really nicely to both
draw me in and invest me but also just have
a lot of you know fun and character and and
Nuance in all the right little places like
part of what I especially liked about this
episode and leading up to this they've demonstrated
is like they're not afraid to set something
up and then have the discussion instead of
making you wait like I feel like a lesser
show would have made you wait for her to confront
him about the art or uh for uh Enid and Ajax
to talk about you know what happened with
her getting invited to the dance and all that
stuff like I think they've made a nice display
of both like an intriguing mystery that even
though we're still pretty convinced of like
what the actual outcome is you know I'm still
like in for it and I think even if like the
outcome we have like a pretty we're committed
to who we suspect I'm still like excited for
the mystery to keep unfolding and for all
the different little elements to keep presenting
themselves because even if it does turn out
to be what we suspect I'm still thrilled by
the Journey of the mystery so yeah because
I'm not uh I would say that if like with the
whole thing which I like don't get me wrong
the show sometimes does throw me for a loop
sure of like okay well he did go to boarding
school or some [__] he was gone military
school clearly has some anger problems yeah
it has to exist before that also goes to serve
the creature
months ago experiences yeah uh yeah it's more
like of course I have my doubts uh but I'm
like no you gotta stay instead of him I gotta
commit this time yeah I gotta stick it through
till the end um so yeah I think that the way
they've handled every character like I'm invested
in in every I like I like watching everyone
yeah when you're coming away from Wednesday
like I really I really enjoy Enid uh a hell
of a lot I think she's great she's she's such
a wonderful boisterous personality I love
watching her the sheriff is great too you
know as much as he can be a hard ass I I like
I think he has a lot of good presents and
I really enjoyed the scene with Bianca and
um Wednesday actually she felt human this
episode right instead of more than just that
scene even her interaction with Xavier when
it came to wipe my memory a lot of times it
has I've been waiting for Bianca to get interesting
because it has just sort of been your queen
bee and your pining over X um and it hasn't
really been that evolved and this was the
time I'm like oh you feel like a a three-dimensional
character now yes absolutely uh Xavier I think
it's something about that tortured artist
kind of character who can sometimes semi-rub
me the wrong way for some reason because you
see too much of yourself in them and you don't
like what you see exactly yeah I'm looking
in a mirror mainly just the looks department
is what I'm looking at not so much the personality
but the looks I don't like seeing a tall good
looking white guy that's right I deal with
that privilege every day it's really hard
the the so sometimes it's perform there's
just something about his performance is that
it's the only one I kind of hover in and out
of it's strange because I always enjoy watching
him I'm never like get off the screen man
I always enjoy watching him but he's the one
who wavers in and out of moments of believability
to me in certain parts of his delivery the
funny thing is you feel about Xavier the way
I feel about time Tyler yeah because I like
Tyler right I actually I do too I enjoy Tyler
a lot but he has to me he has a and and it's
and it's the range of the performance has
grown over these episodes but especially the
first couple I was like he's got a specific
delivery for most of his lives well I think
they're having him to if it is him as the
monster it would stand a reason that they
put him in a certain kind of framework with
the delivery yeah because it's supposed to
be like when you go back and watch the season
this is all it's all hinging off of whether
or not
then it's one of those you're like oh I get
what he's doing now you know yeah um but I
I he could see has the kid from they both
have a variation of kid of the wrong side
of the tracks kind of performance yeah um
but him especially is a normie for now but
Eugene that's sad I was really the second
he decided to go on his own I was like [__]
or like beginning of episode five it's like
oh he's he's okay he's it's not my blood or
something or or hey he'll live at least I
don't know I'm hoping fingers crossed although
like I also I appreciate that with this show
I wouldn't necessarily put it past them it's
like even though you they had that bit with
Rowan where you technically see him he died
so like he could uh Eugene could die and I
think that's an another nice thing about this
show is even though there are elements that
are fun and familiar and that you can sort
of sit and poke and predict I think they're
good at tripping the light in certain moments
where you're pulled out of that and you are
just kind of invested or concerned and this
is a show where actually funny enough like
I think the the love triangle works really
well because I don't I'm like I like them
both I don't know who she'd end up with you
know well it's well Justified yeah sick I'm
kind of sick of love wrinkles but I think
it's well I think the way they the plot weaves
it in and out yeah as well Justified like
I really like how she asked him to the dance
because yeah it was for the ulterior motives
because it wasn't because she actually compelled
to go with at all like she doesn't want to
go to like and the show never even alludes
that she actually wants to go whatsoever yeah
but I love of how they've been using thing
because thing is as adorable as that character
isn't as wonderful as the effects design is
uh he's becoming more of this there's no Uncle
Fester in the show yet but he is becoming
like an uncle in a way of looking out and
wanting her to live have an adolescence a
bit yeah yeah the emotional connection and
stuff yeah I think that's great of how it's
how we manipulated the situation but the that's
what I loved about the writing of it was because
you can see that she's she was negatively
affected by Xavier's um lashing out towards
her over going into the barn and the drawings
and stuff that she was affected by it especially
when he's like I don't care about anyone and
then to be confronted with the Tyler situation
you know like it it was a nice push for her
to be tempted slash guilted into going through
with the dance because she couldn't go through
with that emotion again yeah and I thought
it was really well executed so yeah I think
this was uh I thought this was a absolutely
wonderful episode it had a great pulse about
it and it it never took its foot off the pedal
and uh it had a great it had a lot of fun
and yeah I'm thrown for a loop here must be
two monsters there's gotta be some other yeah
the monster at least has an accomplice or
a helper oh why but I'm forgetting all about
I'm so focused on the monster that I'm like
why was Gwendolyn Christy though not yeah
like why'd she cover Rowan's death yeah that's
what I can't figure out is it the mayor God
it didn't look like at the mayor it's a good
well yeah I mean I feel like there are multiple
part of me wonders like well you know this
whip is bad for Nevermore you know to have
a rampaging creature around especially when
eventually you know you can't pretend it's
a bear forever but uh I don't know I mean
I I have to imagine that with her there's
something yeah more afoot uh but I'm really
curious and I like that I don't really have
like a solid prediction about that other than
just like I don't fully trust her but even
the way they play her even the way they play
Weems like she is she's not one note so like
even though she's chewing a lot of scenery
a lot of the time she is a character who does
experience similar things with the other people
and hearing that she like wanted to go ostensibly
to the dance to the Raven dance with Gomez
and stuff back in the day like they're they're
suspicious things about her but she's also
like enough of a character that yeah I'm sitting
here going I don't know and uh and I wonder
what Miss Thornhill maybe has to do with it
that hasn't been revealed or what the secret
is about her because she's so in plain sight
and there's got to be something more to her
whole thing she's the most mysterious character
at the moment I feel like um I'm just really
great I don't know something you said about
the about the the emotionality of the whole
thing regarding the dance I think it actually
plays really nice to wins again this show
could easily betray its Central character
in a number of ways by needing to engage us
in one way or another but I think the the
way in which you have the I think the triangle
is nice because she could end up with none
of them and it's sort of like watching her
flirt with connection and emotion and the
thing she says about you know I wish I cared
more like that's a less explored and like
a real thing that I'm sure some people go
through and so like I think they've found
very conscientious ways of of giving us emotion
to connect to with Wednesday even though the
bread and butter of the character is sort
of that she's not that way um so yeah there's
there's there's there's like there's more
cleverness at work here than I was expecting
going in I guess she's just gonna ball her
eyes out in the final scene and then and then
yeah just go straight into like a maniacal
laugh she's gonna be wildly sensitive season
two just cried everything all right guys well
what do you think about this episode leave
your thoughts down below uh leave a like subscribe
you can check us on patreon thank you so much
for joining us on this journey and uh last
but not least one is for the patreon got a
shout out Michael B omnimedia Because Omni
media uh other than being a great friend of
mine and also the fact that we uh collaborated
on um tales of the Jedi Coraline we did together
too he has covered Wednesday as well and uh
apparently it's done well for the Channel
people really like his reactions so if you're
looking for more Wednesday reactions I highly
encourage you to go check out Omni media that's
o as in octopus M as in mother and as in Nancy
one is in the number one it's literally the
number one and then the word media uh that's
a really weird thing to search up so Michael
thank you so much for being a great pal and
also um yeah love talking with you all the
time we do talk a lot all the time I ever
stop talking guys several times a week can't
ever get an edge wise I know I know John's
was left out of the conversation when we were
talking slowly just all here across the room
he's peering over my my shoulder with angst
and Jealousy Michael love you new John I I
am uh you know what it's fine I deserve that
you've been here supporting us long enough
you can be me yeah oh
that's what we call you call them around the
reject household old Michael here oh my cool
new John enjoy your name Michael wear it better
than I did I'll do my best to take me out
with Association all right so we're gonna
honor let's see you guys [Music]